she's the co-host of the two funny mamas
podcast
and she's a weight watchers ambassador
give it up for my girl kim winley
[Music]
that's like it's coming times it's been
too long since companionship
exactly i need it i'm gonna do it all
the way down good
i can't do it all the way wait i want to
say it's so good is yours
oh that's good i know it's kind of
dangerous because it tastes just right
but you can still taste a lot of that
alcohol so
you're going to be holding my hair look
at me i'm looking at this um this is
this they're drinking too don't you
worry they're having a good time
yes raise your glasses ladies
so wait this is your fourth time on the
show so
you get it hold on on the show give it
give it some space
give it some space so give it some space
no you get this wonderful gift that we
give people
that have been here four times you're
welcome in advance come on justin oh my
god is it a car
this is a team kelly jacket you're
welcome
to take it thank you what this is kim is
this is uh
well it's leftovers from my season
are you kidding me this is my leftover
jacket
oh my god this is great but uh it's not
that good until you sign it
i get i'll sign it but no i heard that
you liked you like tammy downs because i
heard
um i heard you over at your girlfriend's
house
and you know what i'm talking about you
were taking her rings sherry
you were taking her rings you were
taking all this i have video footage of
you
you were trying to help her pack but
really you were just taking all her
stuff
no no no no no no okay sherry shepherd
takes my things and i'm actually going
back to her house
to get them back wait what you look
guilty in that video with those
bracelets
okay maybe those weren't maybe that was
worth the thing she took
but she has taken things and she's kept
them so i feel like it's only
fair for me to go and get some things
that i might need so like what
that i might need yeah well i thought
you might need a jacket so i got you one
look i appreciate it you didn't even
have to help me come back i just gave it
to you i'm a re-condo'd and just gave it
to
you no but why do i feel like you should
have given me some uh roller skates with
this
oh my god i just bought myself roller
skates
can you roll escape yes but like here's
the thing when i say yes i mean like yes
i did it like my whole life until like
you know maybe not the last 15 years
but like i'm gonna get on them because
my kids are don't worry don't you worry
everybody insurance insurance no i'm
gonna do
that i need to help a helmet and pads
i'm gonna look like such a goofball yes
i got yeah i got roller skates i thought
it would be funny to do okay
i'm gonna roll a skate with you okay
i'll wear my own jacket and look like a
total tool
so wait you were also flirting though
the last time you were here with the
bachelor
matt james so how did it go did you
slide into his dm first of all why do
you know all my business
because i stalk you okay okay i
appreciate that
i have nothing to do with my time now
that i'm single
but you won't be single long girl okay
come hook you up
um now let me tell you matt you saw how
he was talking to me right when we were
on the show yeah
his smile then he he tweeted me oh what
did he say
it was about your show but it still had
my name in it
something something came with me i can't
remember it but it was something
fantastic
so um i want to uh
slide in this dm and i need you to help
me oh okay well i don't know how i can
help
i'm a wreck no you got this okay okay so
this way i got my phone we're gonna make
up a video right
okay okay you ready so this is what
we're gonna do we're gonna i'm gonna act
like i'm singing
okay you gonna say the words and i'm
gonna be mouthing them that's what i
need you to say
okay i need you to say hey matt hey matt
those other girls are whack won't you
come and get a little of this back fat
wait you got it you've got to end it
with something to hold on to
oh yes okay all right that's why it's
there the lord knew
the lord knew okay so you you okay
you're saying i wouldn't be in it you
think okay yeah okay here we go here we
go
you gotta help me okay hey matt
those other girls are whack get you some
back fight
something to hold on to look at that
meat
oh look at that me
yes watch you know mama help you
watch this and watch matt come for me
which matt comes for me
i love you wait it is part d
of our single ladies celebration uh
being a female in comedy
do you date comedians or is that like
cause is that like a musician dating a
musician you maybe shouldn't
exactly okay you should not because say
you're on the road together i know we're
in close quarters
and you something happens you get
together but now they can't go on the
road with you anymore
or you can't go on the road with them
because now they really you know it's
too much now you're working together
now when the girls come after the show
you're watching
no you cannot i okay if you do date a
comedian
you got to be able to pick which one's
going to make it
that's what you got to do like i missed
my shot with kevin hart
i didn't know he was smaller than me and
i was like kevin go on now back
up but i should have gone to a little
fortune teller
i should have talked to somebody a
little psychic or something and said
okay there's this little dude after me
and i like him but he little
uh what you think we both in the same
business if they'd have said
one day he's gonna have all this jumanji
money
yeah i'd have been right there talk
about coming you've come here yeah you
come here
i i love government i love him too he's
funny
he's always been fun oh my god he's so
funny i just saw his recent stand-up
thing he just did but
um so wait with with weight loss
are you are you wearing things that you
didn't think you could
i feel like i do that when i lose weight
i'm like oh these jeans fit again
when you lose a little weight yeah it is
amazing where you lose weight i didn't
know
you lose weight in your feet my feet got
smaller
i went from a 15 to 10. okay
got some clumsy big on me but you know i
was able to fit my shoes and i had these
thigh-high boots
that i could never get up that's my
calves are so the calves
i couldn't get the boots up but i lost a
little bit so i was able to put on some
shoes
and some boots and i'm still on my ww
journey
you look great 30 pounds down
weight watchers forming notice weight
watchers yeah yeah so
whenever you want to join we got a
little number for you i know it's that
whole commitment thing
it's i have an issue with it oh you got
it how about
you can you i'd be able to do it for
three months and then i'd be
like well we did this that's all you
need a pound a week or two but let me
tell you the way
i i even in my thin moments like since
you've been gone days like i have
i have like soccer calves like i'm those
boots never fit me
i always have to go get them like
stretched what's like even in my
thinnest moment like even on american
idol you can see pictures like my
thinnest moments like
i still had to get my cab thing
stretched out i played soccer i got some
calves girl
oh that's why you built yeah don't mess
with me i will kick you
i will win no now that you lifted your
skirt yeah
lifting your skirt i'm not saying
nothing else to you smart
i know i do even though even i know i am
i used to have big calves i'm there yeah
i'm not gonna lift my legs they say like
when i get older it'll be better though
i mean because you lose
muscle or whatever this went very gentle
very quickly
never let it go let it go so can you
tell us
about your your cleavage hack
what's your cleavage hack what oh
who told what how do y'all know about
wait help me out because i got little
bitties
so okay i do have a cleavage hat
what leave a check do you need to leave
a chat because you have a pretty nice
this i'm just saying
they nice and a good bra you take them
take the bra off on a trip
i might fall right here in some audience
right boom right there so wait what's
that
so what you got to do when you want to
look 20.
okay keep them tight i taught this to
sherry shepherd okay you put on a nice
bra
your regular bra yeah then you get a
smaller bra
put that on in the back and when i tell
you they bring you
up about right here into the chin so you
put on
two bras a smaller one and your regular
bra
and boom now you're gonna pass out in
hour three
but hang in there but how did they wake
up
you go wake up like here's my thing
about stuff like that i always get
nervous because people are like
like well you met him looking like that
and it was just like me with no makeup
or whatever like
even my ex-husband i was like well yeah
i don't want to like i don't know i feel
like if i did that
and then there is going to be a point
when my clothes come off and then it's
like you can't hide that
you don't want a false advertisement i
don't know
no no kelly i'm taking you as my little
sister okay
i i got to for this next man you got to
talk to me
okay all this honesty that's for the
birds
[Laughter]
god what's wrong with you
i am to be real and nothing this is all
fakery well nothing i mean it's real
right now grace banks
i have a i have a paper you got you can
you got everything my hair everything
you just you
fool them yeah until you got them i'm
telling you though you
get home though and and the spanx come
off and it's like
opening crescent rolls it's the
pillsbury
you're right yeah yeah i've done that
but once you've really gotten them to
fall for you because see kelly you're
not talking to the men in their eyes
i don't know you're probably just
talking and singing kelly you seem like
you're singing and laughing
but when you talk to them i need you to
be in their eyes in their eyes yeah and
give them
it's the jedi mind trick okay and you're
gonna talk to them and you're gonna use
that little country little southern
folks
yeah you're gonna get them watch that
next month okay
some girls can you fling that hair and
you fling the hair
you fling that are you flinging the hair
okay i need to see you i feel like we're
having our own bend and snap
excuse us for one second y'all i need
you to be coy or i'll just go to dinner
with my girlfriends and die with my dog
and my children
okay i'm gonna wait a couple years and
come back i gotta come back
i gotta give you some time and then i'm
gonna come get you i'm gonna pick you up
in the drop down
and we're gonna go all right yep i'm
still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever